we are coming to you live from the
nation's capital where the Barden
University Bellas are performing for the
president of the United States on his
birthday
oh no she has no underwear on we have a
commando situation she's turning no
races the australian singer gave the
president a birthday gift from Down
Under see fellas are suspended you're
being replaced by the European champion
we are does sound machine how we gonna
people thin I'm not supposed to have any
ideas I'm a hot one I'm pretty sure I'm
the hot one if we win a World
Championships we reinstate us if you win
it Oh bazan Bellas you are so tiny we're
gonna kick your ass your team is like
good how'd you say that the heated mess
a mess where heat is applied to it so
what once was little messy is now oh
here we go he's just retire did your
accents get thicker that like a
intimidation thing because World War two
boom
I look back on this I won't remember
performing and competing I'm gonna
remember you weirdos me too me too okay
guys this is gonna be some haters out
there they're gonna look at us Team USA
and be like why is the most talented one
Australian these girls have broken down
every single barrier in their path
what an inspiration to girls all over
the country who are too ugly to be
cheerleaders we won this money